a
[Música]
desde 2020 la pandemia de kobe 19 y los
encierros han obligado a las marcas de
moda a replantearse sus estrategias de
comunicación
incapaces de desfilar han producido
fashion film este nuevo género
cinematográfico se convirtió en una
apuesta segura el último evento que ha
asegurado su reputación y durabilidad es
el festival de cine de moda de lyon que
celebra su segunda edición abierto a las
escuelas de moda arte cine ya las marcas
es el único festival organizado y
financiado por una institución pública
la universidad de lyon 2 iba en serio
para un diseñador se trata de transmitir
el adn de la marca y el adn de la marca
que lleva los valores a partir de ahí se
trata de algo emocional pero también
axiológico en términos de valores y si
uno está en el proceso de hacer una
película de artista o de estudiante se
recurre en formas de generar conciencia
sobre la moda como un fenómeno que tiene
consecuencias ecológicas que es un
fenómeno totalmente económico y aquí
tenemos películas bastante críticas de
hecho con la industria de la moda sobre
cuestiones de ecología sexy mismo
relaciones de poder entre grupos de
clases sociales
y entonces no es todo menos películas
inútiles en realidad son películas que
invitan a la reflexión
se forma en parís pero volvió a lyon la
ciudad de su infancia que me perdí a
ganador del pública ter 2022 es de lyon
estamos construidos como cualquier
persona por nuestra identidad familiar
por nuestra identidad íntima
hoy se llaman icto porque en icto field
que significa gente que disfruta de la
noche y yo eso es ésa es mi infancia
estaba encerrado en mi habitación pero
por elección propia y haber podido
descubrir mi sexualidad mi identidad
como me sentía cómodo a través de la
ropa a través del disfraz a través del
travestismo a veces porque la ropa es un
elemento de identidad y un factor de
revelación para algunas personas y por
lo tanto para el jurado así que estoy
muy contento el cine de moda es un
género mediático híbrido se inspira
tanto en los códigos del cine como en
los de los vídeos musicales o los
anuncios publicitarios por lo tanto se
necesitaba un jurado heterogéneo para
elegir entre los competidores
podemos sentir que esta joven generación
está muy preocupada por la política mal
clima y cómo no destruir el planeta
y el reciclaje y una pregunta
qué tiene que ver la moda con sus
propias preguntas
es bastante increíble ver hasta qué
punto los estudiantes se han apropiado
de las necesidades que el mundo de la
moda también tendrá que afrontar pero
que son bonitos palancas de desarrollo
porque al final lo que tenemos que ver
es que vamos hacia un mundo mejor y creo
que realmente lo encarnarán tienen una
gran forma de hablar realmente confío en
ellos y creo realmente que este grupo
representa el futuro de la moda
a menudo cuando vemos una película de
moda nos quedamos impresionados
asombrados los bonitos atrás pero creo
que cuando también hay emoción y un
mensaje de trabajo
donde vemos algo y sentimos cosas estoy
pensando en particular en la película
que recibió el premio del estudiante
que realmente me emocionó mucho creo que
es algo muy interesante y ya está
el tema de esta edición de 2022 el
espacio y los espacios
el colectivo 16 horas 25 lo abordó con
elegancia discreción y cortesía
[Aplausos]
especialmente una película en la que se
aborda el tema de la muerte y el tema de
la muerte es muy difícil de abordar en
la literatura y en el cine y aquí me
pareció perfecto la chica me dijo
teníamos miedo de que no nos entendieran
pues lo entendimos todo en cualquier
caso me parecen muy serios
la película programa es una película
sobre el duelo y sobre los ciclos del
duelo existe un paralelismo estético y
simbólico entre los ciclos cortos del
fast fashion y el ciclo largo del luto
así que en primer lugar se refiere al
programa de la lavadora y después a la
obsolencia programada de la ropa porque
finalmente fast fashion significa
colecciones muy rápidas una semana dos
semanas un mes así que toda la ropa que
llevamos está pensada para hacer entre
comillas destruida ya que dentro de un
tiempo pasaron de moda así que también
hay una gran referencia a eso y luego
está el hecho de que finalmente con el
fast fashion todos estamos programados
para seguir la moda y perdemos un poco
de nuestra personalidad así que de hecho
hay una referencia a todo esto de hecho
queríamos hacer una gran metáfora y
también poner una historia con la que
todo el mundo pudiera relacionarse por
ejemplo la historia de amor porque pasa
por varias emociones y pensamos que el
espectador podría mirarla y conocerse y
al mismo tiempo para transmitir
discretamente un mensaje sobre el fast
fashion su lado ligeramente manipulado
manipuló y que todo el mundo pueda tomar
conciencia y decirse a sí mismo bueno si
yo también estoy aquí tal vez no me doy
cuenta pero con esto tal vez abra los
ojos
permanecer atento con los ojos bien
abiertos no enfrascarse en su placer sin
jamás dejarse engañar por él